After years of buildup, Batman finally got
the band together in Justice League to save
the world from certain doom.
But there are still a ton of questions about
how exactly they managed to do it.
So hold on to your Mother Box, because here's
a spoiler-filled look at some of the biggest
unanswered questions in Justice League.
What happened to the Mother Box?
The plot of Justice League revolves around
the villainous Steppenwolf assembling the
Mother Box and almost wiping out the whole
world.
Luckily, Cyborg and Superman team up to pull
the box apart in the nick of time, and everyone
goes away happy.
But what happened to the Mother Box after
that?
Considering it has the power to bend time
and space and destroy entire planets, you'd
think the Justice League would want to keep
a really close eye on it.
But for some reason the box is never seen
again.
And where it ended up is just one big question
we have about the Mother Box, the other one
being…
"what's in the box?
What's in the the f------ box?!"
What about Darkseid?
In Batman versus Superman, we got a whole
dream sequence teasing the arrival of the
ultimate big bad in the DC Extended Universe,
Darkseid.
So it was pretty weird that he was barely
even mentioned in Justice League, especially
considering almost the entire movie is about
him.
See, Steppenwolf works for Darkseid, and the
Mother Box is trying to turn Earth into a
new version of the planet Apokolips.
Which is also where the parademons come from.
And presumably where the boom tube teleportation
tornados lead to.
So this movie was really all about Darkseid.
But when it comes to the DCEU, who is he?
What does he want?
And when is he going to show up on screen?
Those are all questions Justice League asks,
but doesn't answer.
What's the deal with Cyborg?
In Batman versus Superman and Justice League,
we learn that Cyborg's cyborgian bits were
created by the Mother Box, which basically
overwrote his damaged body with Apokoliptian
technology.
Both Aquaman and Cyborg himself raise concerns
that the Mother Box may turn Cyborg against
the Justice League, but other than one stray
missile fired at Superman's face, nothing
comes of it.
Well...nothing comes of it yet.
But what happens when Cyborg faces Darkseid,
the master of Apokolips?
Does the Justice League have an unwitting
mole inside their group, a double agent infected
with an alien virus that's waiting to betray
Earth at just the wrong time?
Maybe before Batman builds his special table
in Justice League Mansion, he should consider
exactly what kind of ticking time bomb he's
letting on the team.
Where was Green Lantern?
In maybe the movie's coolest moment, fans
finally got the see the Green Lantern Corps
brought into the DC Extended Universe in a
flashback sequence, where they team up with
the Amazons, Atlanteans, Old Gods, and regular
schmoes to take down Steppenwolf when he first
attacked Earth thousands of years ago.
One question, though: where the heck was Green
Lantern during the fight at the end of the
movie?
Green Lanterns are basically the beat cops
of the universe, and since Darkseid and the
forces of Apokolips are pretty much the single
biggest threat in that universe, you'd think
an APB would be put out as soon as that Mother
Box starts shimmying.
And yet there's no sign of any Green Lanterns
in the present day at all.
Was he at a cosmic donut shop?
Hopefully the next time the world is about
to be destroyed, he'll bother to show up.
"Stand back and peep the light show! Green Lantern's got this!"
Green
Lantern wasn't the only no show though...
Where was everyone else?
When Steppenwolf attacked thousands of years
ago, a massive alliance came together to stop
him.
This time around, though, a handful of weirdos
in costumes are the only people who bother
to lift a finger.
So where was everyone else?
For no apparent reason, the Amazons suddenly
aren't allowed to leave their island.
But why weren't the Atlanteans there to help
the Justice League?
How about, you know, the Russian Army, who
had to be wondering about what was going on
at that reactor site?
And what about other characters in the DC
Extended Universe, like the Suicide Squad?
Remember them?
"I want to assemble a task force of the most
dangerous people on the planet."
It seems really weird that nobody else on
the planet cared whether or not Earth was
destroyed.
How do they explain Clark's return?
Most of Justice League revolves around how
much the world needs Superman, and the team's
successful efforts to bring him back to life.
But how is anyone going to be able to spin
Clark Kent's revival without giving away the
obvious fact that he's Superman? Clark got
an obituary and a funeral in Batman versus
Superman, but now he's back in his old house,
and walking the streets of Metropolis like
nothing ever happened.
Between that and Lois referring to Superman
as "Clark" right out in the open, it seems
like they may have brought back Superman only
to kill his secret identity in the process.
Who is in the Legion of Doom?
Finally, we just have to ask: who else is
going to be in Lex Luthor's Legion of Doom?
So far in the end credits scene, we have Lex
and Deathstroke the Terminator, but if the
Super Friends cartoon is any indication, we
can expect to see more villains in the future.
The Joker, of course, has already shown up
in Suicide Squad, but other bad guys like
Black Manta, Captain Cold, and the Cheetah
have yet to make their debuts in the DC Extended
Universe.
Frankly, we don't care who is on the team
— as long as Lex trades in that yacht for
a headquarters that looks like Darth Vader's
helmet and rests at the bottom of a swamp.
Give the fans what they want!
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!